[Music]  kendall Jenner  Megan Markel and more stars are speaking  out on International Women's Day I mean  it's awesome Kendall is one of many  celebs featured in this W Magazine video  please respect yourself respect women  Haley Baldwin Sienna Miller and Bella  Hadid also joined because women's rights  women's rights women's rights are human  rights I guess I'm doing something right  and check out Megan's message on Twitter  a famous poem by nedra wahid about how  your worth doesn't come from your  outward beauty 35 year olds wrote quote  - always knowing your Worth and so if we  treat ourselves like our own best  friends I think that it's like having  the best cheerleader ever with you which  seems so simple but it really is a game  changer